pod 74 going out over those 5g airwaves
don't touch that dial because it is a
banger
post post humanism
[Music]
and if you know there is anything that
makes me feel post-human it is
recording before noon thank you victor
for uh confusing the time zones
our guest was at one time in toronto but
he since uh fled to the
vast canadian wilderness
the most sought after canadian
destination winnipeg manitoba
[Laughter]
anyway today's episode is marked by the
absence of matt
or you might say the yawning chasm of
matt's absence but matt needed a break
because he spent this week on the very
front lines of praxis
which of course for
he as well as the rest of us is arguing
on twitter
with uh esteemed conservative
intellectual james lindsey the author of
race marxism so matt reviewed his book
if you if you heard the last exclusive
episode matt reviewed his book um and
you know he loved it
let's call a snowflake a snowflake he
got mad triggered yeah even changed his
twitter handle oh you mean uh yeah james
lindsay pissing off jacobins well he did
the thing the thing that they usually do
which is i'm not triggered you're
triggered oh yeah that was great yeah um
i think jen james lindsey's trying to
make a name for himself because after
this podcast so thoroughly
dismantled jordan peterson and put him
to bed
lindsay saw his opportunity to ascend
the throne of
uh you know right-wing
internet intellectualism
but with the very puzzling claim that
hegel is responsible for critical race
theory and to be honest i have no idea
who the audience is for this yeah it's
uh it's pretty weird because i
understand the appeal of like self-help
joseph campbell
joseph campbell being of course the uh
original writer of star wars
but i understand why an alienated
internet-brained 20-year-old who gets
his philosophy from youtube would enjoy
hearing about how he's the center of the
story of the entire universe but it
really is a new bent for the right wing
to go oh yes
hegel that great leftist
intellectual bent on the destruction of
civil society
yeah you know james lindsay positioned
himself pretty strongly in that
so-called square hoax anyway with uh
sending all those fake articles to a
bunch of journals and and then having
this big you know gotcha moment against
the humanities yeah i really you know i
i wasn't following it too closely i saw
that i saw the tweets back and forth
between matt mcmanus and james lindsay
and it was some was just generally like
delighted that uh it was like that he
responded to it and felt the need to
respond to it but um
yeah i mean that whole hegel thing
is pretty interesting i think it seems
like there's a there's a very um
it's like having i think conservative
sort of like misunderstanding philosophy
or accusing philosophy of all kinds of
ills maybe that's not a new phenomenon
but i feel like it's having its new
moment right now no i love the idea that
uh you know hegel supposedly created a
critical race theory sorry i'm just
holding up my big copy of the logic
which i dutifully carry around with me
everywhere i go
um yeah no i'm all in for that
hegel has the origin of uh critical race
theory and cultural marxism
although people who have read hegel's uh
you know philosophy of world history
might uh disagree but that's maybe a
longer conversation
yeah he's long he's been considered a
racist long long before being considered
the founder of critical race there
anyway we digress we digress matt is
recovering from his time on the front
lines
um of course leaving an irreducible lack
in the ontological structure of the
podcast but do not fear there is a
symptom and today the symptom is matt
a new mat joining us
matthew matthew flistfetter our guest
how are you how are you doing matt
you've heard you've heard his voice for
one sentence thus far but how are you
i'm i'm doing great thanks for having me
on the podcast
looking forward to talking yeah
excellent well
matt before we turn yourself
over to you
damn we are getting leukemian already
you should never do self-analysis though
no self-analysis
oh yeah
good advice before we turn yourself over
to you eric is going to fill
the audience in on what they are to
expect
or or rather what they desire if we're
going to be on theme here
and then we'll proceed from there right
so today we have uh as we've been saying
a guest with us matthew flistfetter
professor matthew flisfeter is an
associate professor of rhetoric and
communication
at the university of winnipeg where he
teaches
communication theory critical theory
discourse ideology is a range of
interests and
he's written a number of books
three of them are
single authored books and one of them is
a collection
um on ggi and media studies
to which he's also a contributor
professor matthew flisfetter is also
currently the recipient of a social
science and humanities research council
insight grants
in support of his project
which is entitled the hysterical sublime
a critical study of the aesthetics
rhetorics and ethics of new materialist
and post-humanist critical theory
okay so this is a project uh flesfetter
is currently working on and um
my understanding is of it is that it is
a critique
of post-humanism
um
and in in uh maybe good hegelian
double negation fashion he's
articulating himself as a
anti-anti-anthropocentrist so he's a
he's real he's he's against this um
strain of
anti-anthropocentrism
that has um crept into um
contemporary critical theory by way of
uh
you could say post-modern philosophy and
post-structuralism
as it has been
sort of ramified and extended into these
new movements that we call
you know new materialism post-humanism
object-oriented ontology vitalist
materialism and so on
i think um
bruno latour i think graham harmon and
even think of the contributions of uh
duluz and guateri in uh thinkers like
rosie berdotti
all very great stuff
yeah all very interesting uh all very
interesting theory uh that's emerged um
but not today
but today we're gonna be taking a
critical look at this strain of um
opposition to human exceptionalism uh
the idea that human beings are somehow
let's say unique or exceptional for
various reasons usually because of their
use of language
and that sort of thing so matthew
flusfetter is critical of this idea of
um moving away from
anthropocentrism so i'll turn it over to
uh flis fetter now if if you could just
tell us a little bit
about the say origin of uh this project
and how it sort of carries forward
themes
uh from your earlier work i should
mention the latest book you wrote um
was published last year um it's called
uh algorithmic desire
uh toward a new structuralist theory of
social media and um this idea of a new
structuralism
is is also very interesting so i turn it
over to uh you matt if you could um
maybe
maybe open up some of the key issues
that you're thinking about right now
yeah sure no that's a great uh great
opening question i'm very happy to be
here again
so um yeah you you mentioned so a lot of
it is the critique of post-humanism but
there's
i guess what i'm trying to do there's
some continuity in the
overall trajectory of the work that i'm
doing largely based in
i'd say i'm more more of a zijax scholar
zuziak and frederick jameson um are
probably the two biggest influences um
on my work and via both uh zhizhak and
jamison rethinking lecon rethinking
hegel really
away from the the way that they have
been interpreted by a lot of
um you know the from the the 1950s 1960s
going forward in french philosophical
circles thinking of um you know and even
the way it's been translated into
english critical and cultural theory la
con as a post-structuralist um and even
um as a structuralist thinker hegel as a
pan-logisticist monist um thinker i
think that a lot of what i've been
trying to do via zizek and jamison is to
re-articulate the relevance and the
significance of the work of uh hegelah
and lacombe um but of course always
still with a kind of a marxian politics
um in the background
excellent excellent this sounds uh
more or less like standard fare and i'm
excited to get to the discussion oh by
the way listeners there's a a link in
the description to the paper that we're
discussing in more depth and it is uh
worth a look either before or after you
listen to the conversation
though just before we get to the
theoretical side of your position here
it's worth mentioning at least to us as
it was a hometown event
uh that matt you were something of an
organizer for the
infamous peterson zizek debate here in
toronto and i did not attend it but
one of us did
uh victor you wanted to ask about this
right
so okay i mean i think we were talking
on twitter a while back and and you know
you mentioned to me that you were
actually were the organizer of that zach
peterson debate and i was actually there
up in the nosebleeds uh it was quite a
scene you know it was really interesting
to be in line and try to try to identify
okay who's the peterson bro who's the
who are the shizhak people here just
look for the three-piece suits yeah the
different and the different moments of
cheering and laughing right like in
different sections of the audience it
was look for the sad girlfriends
that got dragged here
i think that would be on both sides
let's be honest okay um
anyway well not always but so i guess
maybe how did that come about um and how
was that experience for you
um yeah so
something i don't actually get to talk
about quite often it's really i mean it
was such a weird way that it came about
so
um i've known slavoy for a number of
years and i had arranged for him to come
and uh give a talk here at the
university of winnipeg
and
it was
late december
probably christmas eve or before i don't
even celebrate christmas but it was like
christmas eve or something and i get an
email from slavoy um peterson has
challenged him he says peterson's
challenged him to a debate but um he
doesn't know who to contact what to do
about it can i he asked me can i can i
be the person to arrange
it and you know
oh [ __ ] um you know and zlatan's he's
been very kind to me in a number of ways
and i said okay well let me see what i
can do so i wrote i just you know
googled peterson and found his email
address and i wrote to him
and i said you know salva's been in
touch with me he wants to do a debate
can't we do this and i think within a
minute i got a response from peterson
right away i'm gonna hook you up with my
team now one of the things that i think
is you know it was a very very
interesting experience working with that
and i was the one i i negotiated all the
details on starboy's end and i had to
work with um peterson's uh entire team
his management his publicist
the the people organizing now one of the
things that actually disturbed me quite
a bit that i heard running after the
debate from a lot of people criticizing
slavoy is how can you debate peterson
how are sorry how can you how can you
platform peterson how can you give
peterson a platform which when i saw
that that was the funniest thing because
stop platforming this new york times
number one best seller well that's it
right and if you if you understand the
entire culture industry apparatus that's
behind
peterson i mean i sort of
kept you know i'm going to keep going
forward because peterson's
platforming someone who i think is one
of the most important philosophers of
our time and he's you know
giving uh
an audience to this person that many of
these people probably would have never
heard of you know other than in our
little niche circles i don't think that
subway is really yet a household name
until now right
so it was a very interesting experience
um working uh and hammering out all
those details i think that there's a lot
of people who think they know about
behind the scenes but don't actually
know the behind the scenes you know the
stuff of the what with the one that
killed me
most was that slavoy's just you know
cash grab type of thing people don't
know that he donated um his uh
what he got from the debate to uh the
caring society which is a canadian
charity that supports indigenous
families and children right so i mean
you know and well you know to p it's
interesting to peterson's credit i do
actually remember that at the very
beginning of the debate peterson did
actually say that that's livevoid was
giving it to the to a charity he didn't
say what the charity was and the reason
i remember that so clearly was because i
was waiting for him to say that he was
giving his money to charity but then he
didn't say anything right that's right
and he didn't
um
so but you know
i mean
again with on peterson's side you can
say what you want about peterson but uh
you know the way that he prepared or
ordinary
for the for for the debate i mean it was
a very very i think a useful
not necessarily debate as many people
have pointed out they agreed on a lot of
points but it was a very useful
conversation at least for me and seeing
some of the responses from peterson fans
on reddit on youtube and other spaces
the way that they responded to to
zhizhak right and that you know at the
very least you know
slavoy being kind of like a gateway drug
to alternative way of thinking that a
lot of people may not have ever
encountered before and i have you know
lots of my friends locally here my
family back home in toronto you know
most of these people have not
encountered zhizhak's view of hegel
marxism
so forth and we're much more inclined to
support peterson and coming away from
this saying wow i need to learn more
about this guy saboy jizek i need to
read more about this guy slavoy jijek
and i think that that's to me not beyond
the
challenging of the postmodern
neo-marxists which i thought was great i
think that was to me and i think
everybody the the best moment of the
entire debate because i think that i
mean myself included i have a lot of not
necessarily the same but similar
critiques of the kinds of theorists that
peterson's poking at foucault erida who
i value very much when are very critical
of um that are not marxist and they're
they're avowedly anti-marxist in their
orientation so that one moment i think
to me was central for the debate and
forcing people to really think okay well
what is marxism um how do we do it and
the other thing too i you know you see a
lot of people who say i could have done
a better debate against peterson i could
have actually defended marxism better
than
a lot of people saying this but the you
know at the end of the day peterson
didn't want to talk to any of those
people he wanted to talk to jijek right
he wanted to talk to jijek he wanted to
and
in some sense there's a part of my book
um on social media and algorithmic
desire i talk about the movie gone girl
where i see that as actually a very
radical revolutionary type film because
the hero in that film she knows that the
best way to make a change is to perform
for the camera to play a persona to you
know change things by using the level of
appearances and i think that that's
something that's central to
um socialist debate left wing debate i
don't know what you want to call the the
politics here but using the level of the
performance there as a way to make a
change in the real right and i think
that's something that a lot on a lot of
people on the left don't quite really
aren't getting yet rhetoric matters
appearance matter right this is
something that i think has to be built
into and it's the same reason why even
in the language that i'm using around
humanism as opposed to say socialism or
communism i think that this is something
that you know through the rhetoric
itself will interpolate a public that is
interested in making the kinds of
ethical changes that require
yeah yeah no doubt and and the fear of
platforming also is a very
contemporary social media specific
thing to say as if platforming is a
one-way street and in this case i think
it's obvious uh though maybe not to
everybody that peterson was platforming
gg
at least as much as the other way around
but uh
whether media events are productive or
whether the spectacle
is
worth it is already a problem for
feed-brained moralist posters to figure
out on their own time so have at it it's
maybe this algorithmic desire or
algorithmic juice in action that by the
way is the title of one of matt's other
books
but for today turning now to the current
topic
we're looking at
an article your article
a renewal of humanism against
post-humanist critiques
so it's big
it's broad it'll be put into book form
but matt um could you introduce us to
the motivation to renew
humanism
so the origins of this current project
that i'm working on there there's a
number of origins really um before the
book that you mentioned the last one
algorithmic desire i wrote a little book
on um postmodern theory and the movie
blade runner
so i spent a number of years rethinking
and re-examining um post-modernism
largely through a marxist critique of
post-modernism that comes out of
frederick jameson's work
and then when i was working on
my social media book one of the things
that really struck me in the way that
somebody like bruno bastilles who's a
reader of uh zijak's work
um
he he wrote and a student of baju and he
referred to
zizek and laclau and moof as trying to
develop what he called a a new theory of
structural causality so if you remember
so in the work of louis althusser
altoser's structural marxism the idea
that class struggle and history for
instance are this absent cause that we
can only read through the structures of
their emergence the idea that the the
the cause is developed and understood in
its own effect but there was sort of
this closed version of the structure
that didn't really leave any room for
the agency of the subject apart from
being a symptom of the structure or an
epi phenomenon of the structure and what
bastille's locates in lakla and mufin
and
is this idea of a
open structure so a non-closed and
non-total and non-complete structure
where you can find in the work of zija
for instance and other neolikanian
philosophers from the slovenian school
like maladan dolar like alenka
zupanchich this idea that the subject is
what emerges not because of ideology but
the subject is what emerges at the
failure of ideology when ideology fails
when we encounter the limits of the
structure or in lacanian terms the
symbolic order when we encounter the
limits when we experience contradiction
this is not something that we just that
we need to overcome in kind of the older
more phenomenological
or existentialist um
sort of kojevian humanist idea of trying
to escape contradiction what we start to
understand is that the experience of
contradiction is only is really where we
discover the presence of the subject so
in my little book by not my little book
but on my my last book on uh social
media what i was trying to do there was
trying to think about the form and the
structure of social media in terms of
this idea of a new structuralism that
imagines the the the subject not as an
epi phenomenon of the structure but
rather as what emerges when we realize
the gaps or the lacks or the
contradictions within the structure but
as i was doing this i was trying to
start i was starting to think about um
you know what is this idea of subject
and what was what were some of the
criticisms of the notion of subject
found in the marxist humanist work again
in phenomenology and existentialism that
we really see the criticism of uh with
the development of levy strauss's
structuralism that we see in altius or
structural marxism and of course later
on in the post-structuralisms of
foucault
and so forth so i kind of had in mind
this idea of trying to think about is it
possible to redevelop to redeploy
through uh zhizhak
mainly zijak's reading of hegel is it
possible to rethink this idea of not
just a human subject but also a humanist
politics and a humanist ethics now i'll
say that this is kind of an odd project
for me because zizek is very much an
avowed anti-humanist frederick jameson
too is a very much an avowed
anti-humanist and i know that some
people like to peg them as humanist uh
thinkers and that's part of probably a
longer conversation and i've been in
dialogue with zizek about the way to re
to think his
humanism so the difficulty is um you
know really trying to elaborate on this
idea of what it means to to rethink the
notion of humanism through the work of
validly uh anti-humanist uh thinkers now
i'll just say quickly the other sort of
influence uh on this current project is
when i was working on the postmodernism
book
especially in the work of frederick
jameson he had this little idea that
doesn't really explore anywhere else um
but he writes about this idea of
hysterical sublime he talked about this
kind of hysterical sublime in his
post-modernism work and the best he can
come up with there is he talks about the
role of the sublime in the aesthetic
philosophy of edmund burke and immanuel
kant and where to be somewhat reductive
here talking about the sublime as the
way in which the human subject
experiences or grasps nature and in that
grasping of the nature the irrational
nature outside of humanity that we come
to gain a sense of our own humanity and
in other in in some sense put ourselves
into the picture of radical and critical
thinking even if you see this in kant
that the in the critique of judgment
that the way to begin to think
dialectically and rationally is by
initially positing the presupposition of
an externality of nature out there
against which we think in reason now
what jamison does is he argues that the
sublime of postmodern culture is not
nature but technology
and in um
in trying to think against the the the
the emergence of new media new
technology um computer technology that
we see sort of
depicted in movies like 2001 space
odyssey the terminator the matrix
um
and even today tv shows like black
mirror that we sort of posit the sublime
other of our society as a technology
that we should be fearful of now the
last thing i'll say is that what i'm
trying to do then is to take this idea
of the emergence of a technology that we
should be fearful from and to combine
that with the way that a lot of the
anthropocene discourse is arguing that
too much of a human footprint um in the
way that we've developed technology is
causing our climatological conundrum so
that the fear of technology in some ways
comes to stand in as a fear of the human
as such and that's why we have these
ideas you know anthropocentrism
anthropocene but there are other writers
like uh
james w moore uh
for instance sorry jason w moore uh for
this idea of the capitalist scene that
the problem is not so much the human
footprint but it's the systems and the
structures are the mode of production
that is um not inherent to humanity but
it's something built constructed that we
can in fact change and transform and i
like this idea of thinking about
structures that we can change and
transform which requires some kind of
human ethical action um taking place so
it's in those terms that i'm trying to
rethink the idea of humanism and
anthropocentrism i hope that makes sense
i know i said a lot there
well that's a that's a great intro
great intro summary to the project um
just so we can get everybody up to speed
i was wondering if we could define
a couple terms because we hear
transhumanism being thrown around
we hear you saying humanism and or
post-humanism and return to humanism
and specifically that zizek is an
anti-humanist so i wondered if you could
uh rather quickly i know this this is
this is a book topic
but kind of define where you see the
bleeds and the boundaries between those
different terms
prefixes plus human yeah i'm glad that
you asked that it's a it's a great
question and i think that these are
terms
um that you know are still kind of in
in translation because i don't think
that you know any two people are going
to agree on what these terms mean and i
think that a lot of the pushback that i
get is when i try to say posthumanism is
this or posthumanism is that
so i'm going to tell you how i interpret
these terms and i know that there are
many who might disagree
with me here so i'll begin then with the
way i understand an older marxist
humanism which is absolutely not the
kind of humanism that i'm trying to
develop here and in fact i'm trying to
move away from what i'm interpreting as
an older marxist humanism which if you
look at the work of somebody like eric
fromm or even some of the early work of
andre lefebvre they're arguing for some
kind of substantial
essential
connection between humanity and nature
and they're drawing largely on marx's
early
later published um
1843-1844
economic and philosophical manuscripts
this idea of humanity as existing in
coordination with nature as a species
being that at some point gets alienated
from nature and that the project of the
marxist humanisms of people like from
and uh
is this sort of recombination of
humanity with some substantial nature so
if the problem is a contingent
alienation then their politics the
marxist humanist politics is one of a
disalienation to recombine
humanity with some kind of substantial
nature which is interesting for me
because i think that there's a lot of
similarities with the project of
post-humanism so
i'll get back to that in one second
because i'll first one is something
about anti-humanism so it varies because
in the work of louis althusser
the idea here and there's a number of
sources for alduster's anti-humanism one
is his argument that stalinism was in
some ways too humanist in being
somewhat teleologically driven
historicist economist and more or less
this idea that you could plan and
organize
the economy ignoring the
class struggle as the motor of history
so for altoser in some ways
stalinism was too humanist now the other
side of that was after
the death of stalin um the soviet union
started to avow this new policy of
humanism of peaceful coexistence between
the the
east and west and a lot of the french
communist party the main philosophers of
the french communist party were they
were a stalinist party so they adopted
the stalinist party line of adopting
official humanism so officers
anti-humanism was sort of in reaction to
that official humanism of the of the
soviet union the communist party of the
soviet union and the communist uh the
french communist um party but the other
argument that altaser was making was
that there's a distinct break in marx's
work from his early period to his later
period his early period which was much
more ideologically humanist and then his
later period which was much more
scientifically objective in the
objective analysis as opposed to the
subjective analysis or the moralistic
analysis
of capital so althusser's anti-humanism
is really one of trying to emphasize
some kind of scientific objective
analysis of of capitalism of history
really so seeing history uh class
struggle as the motor of history and not
the the subjective aspect of the you
know people making conditions um
uh out of situations that are not their
own
now the other
way anti-humanism is built into
althusser and in some ways la con is
drawing on claude libby's house in his
structural anthropology and in uh his
book the savage mind very famously in
kind of a retort to uh jean-paul sartre
makes this claim that the goal of the
sciences is not to
constitute humanity but to dissolve it
so there's this sense that the goal is
to try to move away from this notion of
subject i should say too that the the
humanism of satra um phenomenological
existential in some ways drawing on
heidegger in some ways moving away from
heidegger is simply this idea that our
existence precedes our essence that our
material materiality our
our being in the world precedes comes
before
our search for some kind of essence
which in a way it it speaks to the
secular dimensions of a humanism where
there is nobody that can hold us to
account other than ourselves right that
we are the legislators of our ethics of
our morality that no you know divine
being no being outside of us can hold us
to account other than ourselves so levi
strauss is sort of responding in some
ways to
humanism in that way and the the the
anti-humanism of the post-structuralists
like foucault
for instance in some ways i see them as
very much kantian if we think about
kant's project
as one of where we are able only to know
our knowledge of things but we cannot
know things in themselves so there are
the things outside of our knowledge our
discourses our representations and for
the post-structuralist anti-humanists i
think that that still carries because
what they emphasize foucault for
instance emphasizes that we cannot know
truth outside of discourse or that truth
is but an effective discourse so all we
can know are our representations of
truth but we cannot know truth itself
you know again drawing somewhat on on a
high degree and destruction of
metaphysics of presence this idea that
um
that every imposition of a structure
it creates a center of knowledge right
and that center of knowledge imposes
some form of power so there's this
operation of de-centering the subject of
de-centering the human right so all
these are the various different types of
uh
anti-humanism right
now
post-humanism i think is different from
anti-humanism in the sense that whereas
anti-humanism
emphasizes our ability only to know our
knowledge of things but not things in
themselves post-humanism wants to argue
that we can get directly at this
knowledge of things in themselves you
know think of it as thing philosophy we
can know the reality the objective
reality of the world in some way and
that what moved us away from it or
mystifies it is too much human centrism
right too much human centrism so this is
where i think posthumanism is different
in this way from anti-humanism right
does that kind of do these things
sort of make sense
it's a lot to unpack
yeah
yeah no they're they're hanging together
for me um
my my understanding as well just to sort
of editorialize is that
humanism is also associated not just
with marxist humanism but with liberal
humanism as well which in a certain way
accompanies the rise of
capitalism
post post-industrial revolution humanism
was offered almost as a
as a kind of
justification
for the human beings you know this this
quest to dominate nature this quest to
produce new technologies make our lives
easier and more convenient
and to
can i just interject i just want to
interject there because i mean i think
you're making you're making a very good
point and i think that it's very
important to distinguish between a
liberal conception of humanism a marxist
conception of humanism and then the kind
of humanism that i'm trying to renew uh
in my own work and i think that the an
important distinction to make between
let's say the liberal project and the
marxist project first of all i think
that we have to recognize that there is
a kind of benefit in some way to the
historical development of liberalism in
the sense that it for the first time
acknowledges this idea of formal freedom
right that you have to have the formal
idea the concept of freedom before we
can develop it into actual freedom now
where i think what's important here for
me at least is the coincidence of
liberal political philosophy and the
emergence of the capitalist mode of
production in the sense that if we think
about you know when when we look at
marx's um capital volume one i kind of
like to read marx's capital volume one
and i'm drawing here somewhere both reya
dennis
danielevskaya and
who's kind of like a theoretical
opponent to officer both agree that
marxism is not a political economy but a
critique of political economy and if we
think of capitalist critique of
political economy i think it's useful to
actually think of it not just as an
analysis of political economy but as
analysis of bourgeois ideology which in
some way it begins with this idea of the
individual
struggling against nature right that the
the individual determines its existence
whereas what marx is trying to do is to
show the the not the individual but the
socially determined individual in the
same way you kind of see this in hegel's
philosophy of rape when he's talking
about the market logic of competition
that even though individuals enter into
competition with each other we still all
rely on each other for the mutual
production of our means of subsistence
now in liberal humanism i think that the
key idea is that the human is a property
owner is somebody who owns property
right that you are human that you are
human in the eyes of law as opposed to
let's say you know in slavery where
you're not an owner of property you're
not even just without property you are
yourself property right that it's
dehumanizing in that way in the context
of uh liberal humanism and liberal
capitalism so that for capitalism and
liberalism
the human is a property owner even the
wage laborer is considered human because
we supposedly own
our labor power as commodity that we can
sell on the market so the wage form in
some way still is a way of instilling
this idea of the commodity that we own
that gives us our humanity in the
liberal humanist sense now the
difference between that and the marxist
sense is i think that marxist humanism
is still trying to
actualize the merely formal freedom that
is proposed by liberal humanism and and
these um and these philosophies also
connect up to a kind of periodizing
scheme that we're talking about as well
between modernism and postmodernism
and i guess maybe the best way to
approach this would be to talk about
your concept of subjectivity
um which which you get through
lacan and the idea that
we locate subjectivity in a kind of um
in a kind of
let's say a gap or a break that opens up
in the symbolic
and that gap in the symbolic is filled
in or covered over by a kind of fantasy
i'm probably going to get this wrong
a fantasy right and we know
description of ideology is that a um is
that
ideology is is the way we imagine our
our own relationship to our material
conditions of our being
and that
you take this idea though and you
and you run with it maybe you can help
me out here and expand on this where do
you locate subjectivity and how does it
relate to
your project
sure that's a really good question and i
guess i would say that i draw largely
from zhizhak and again i would draw
largely from um
interpretation of lacon and i draw on
his um uh his zlatan interpretation of
hegel and his hegelian interpretation of
the khan here so there's a number of
ways that we can think about this first
of all
you know we're going to alter sir uh i
said it before but i'll repeat it and
i'm drawing off of something that um
zhizhak's colleague in the slovenian
school
he says that for
all to sir
um
subjectivity is a function of ideology
that subject is
what emerges through the structure of
ideology um ideology interpolates
individuals as subjects but for delaware
he says that for lacong um subject is
what emerges when ideology fails now i
want to kind of come at this actually
from the opposite end from the starting
point of subjectivity so we i i began
here by talking about subject as
emerging at the failure of ideology or
as a limit or the point of contradiction
within the symbolic or the structure but
i think that we could also look at it
and this might be a longer explanation
but we can also look at it from the
point can i interrupt you just a sec
sorry before we go sorry sorry yeah
we're just going through a complex line
of reasoning over several centuries and
i just wanted to editorialize on
on behalf of the listener so we have
humanisms as you discussed marxist
liberal
stalinist you mentioned particularly in
the french communist
context
and then the not humanists or
anti-humanists if if you prefer so we're
around 1950 1960 here and not yet at the
post-human turn but i wonder if you
could clarify for the listener
uh what or who
the subject is at this time because for
a long time
and this is the defining feature our a
defining feature of humanisms
is that subjects and humans are
interchangeable more or less humans are
subjects and subjects are humans
um so what is the context of the split
or the division that takes place with
the linguistic turn uh with the
development of psychoanalysis
and how is it that the subject now
comes to be considered separately from
the human being
okay so i should say the difference
between
human and subject so we're talking about
human we're just talking about our our
biological existence our species
existence the fact that we are you know
of nature we are in you know we are
natural bodies we're a subject here in
some ways combines two operations that
uh it combines the operation of our
conscious self our self-awareness but
also our unconscious self which is tied
to things like our desire fantasy and
enjoyment um and so on so i think that
we can we can look at the difference
between just you know a human being and
the human subject if we think about the
origin point of subjectivity um in the
kenyan and
sense now
one way to do that
is
to think about how we are all born into
the world and that precedes us right we
are born into a world of um a society
with values with norms um
and we don't become subject you know
automatically by being born into the
world but at a certain point
what here i'm drawing on lacanian theory
at certain point we start to
think of a sense of self independently
of our parents let's say right and we
realize that we we want to we don't even
have like a sense of who we are outside
of the mother or the father who satisfy
all our needs and this is in la khan's
idea of the mirror stage is the
formation of the ego where you see
yourself reflected in the in the in the
in the mirror and you start to realize
yourself outside of yourself and you
start to develop this ideal sense of
yourself as a wholeness right but at the
same time you also want to satisfy the
desire of your parents right that my
parents say i'm this they my parents say
i'm this they know they want me you know
to the to look like this or to act like
this i think my parents gender me and so
on and so forth they give me a name and
at a certain point we have to make a
decision right we have to what zija
refers to as a forced choice right a
forced choice of being now another way
to think about this fourth choice of
being is zhizhak draws on laka's
interpretation of the cartesian kojito
the i i think therefore i am
and in one point of lakhan's seminar in
seminar 11
lakhan argues we should divide i think
and i am thinking and being we should
divide the two
and in seminar 11 lakhan argues that the
subject is condemned to choose thinking
over being
but later on in his seminar 14 lakhan
argues that we still split it i think
that i am but we are condemned to being
and thinking is relegated to the
position of the unconscious
now what i take here is this idea that
when we choose being
every act of choice
combines
an affirmation and a negation every time
you choose something you're negating all
of the other possibilities that exist
out there
so we choose an initial identity that
limits us that limits us and we're
trying to satisfy the desires of others
out there but while we limit ourselves
in choosing this identity we're also at
the same time negating all of those
other things that become lost they
become the the the latcanian lost object
the fantasy object of all those things
that i think i can get that will
completely complete me but i think oh i
can't get that because it's being
limited or prohibited by uh
some other entity right my parents
society and so on and the whole process
of fantasy is this idea of pursuing
these lost objects that we think will
when we get them they will complete us
and if we complete ourselves then we'll
have full absolute enjoyment and that's
one way to think about the relation of
desire to subjectivity but then the
other thing that lacan and zizek say is
that
in the
failure to gain the thing that we think
we've lost we're actually still getting
enjoyment what's called drive that we're
still getting enjoyment because what
we're enjoying although we don't realize
it
is this unconscious satisfaction of
reaffirming the initial choice that we
made to limit ourselves
so subject emerges in this kind of
paradoxical contradictory relationship
of i've chosen the thing that i'm going
to be but i don't realize that i've made
this free choice you know to be that's
what i'm going to be and everybody's
prohibiting me for being this other
thing that i'm going to be
and the end of analysis the re-emergence
of subjectivity is this moment of
realization that i have always had this
freedom to be able to choose and limit
myself right that i can it's not just
this you know stupid distinction between
you know freedom from and freedom too
that there's al they always happen in
coincidence coincidence with each other
that i impose my own limits and i follow
the own structure my own structure of
laws that i give to myself and that's
how i enact my freedom as a subject you
know or another way to think about it
even is you know if we're a human being
is what we are but subject is tied to a
freedom that allows us to negate the
conditions of what we are right freedom
is being able to say no i won't be this
i won't do that whether you know we may
be determined by the by the base the
superstructure might be determined by
the base but in the superstructure we
can negate the conditions in the base
themselves right i might be born you
know you know this you know religion or
this sex but i can in my freedom negate
the conditions of which i am given and
that's how i enact my freedom and that's
where subject emerges here in the way
that i'm using it
right
um so i i'd like to ask does that
clarify or
yeah i think it does yeah i think it
does well
we're on track here now having
rhetorically performed a kind of
humanism or versions of humanisms
and performed a bit of the impetus for a
non or anti-humanism but we're here
today
together
to try to renew a humanism against what
you've called matt a performative
contradiction in
post-humanism so barring any objections
why don't we try to get a feel for that
debate uh which is far more contemporary
than what we've been discussing so far
um so i'm so i'm curious about sort of
like kind of bringing it to the to the
paper um that we all read which will be
in the description i believe is it true
that it's just like publicly available i
think that it's not behind a paywall or
is that just am i imagining that i think
at the moment on project news it's
available but also the journal itself
has its own website and it'll be free
forever on the journey's website for
public for postmodern culture okay
awesome awesome so yeah so our listeners
can uh can take a look at it i mean i
found it to be a very provocative uh
interesting paper and of course i come
at things from a perspective where you
know i'm not as ensconced in these
debates uh about like
structuralism and post-modernism i'm a
political theorist you know but but i i
i engage it because a lot of my work
ends up engaging people like lacalau
muff and some of these radical democrats
so like i kind of know it through that
but but i'm not i'm not taking it out on
but i did do an m.a at york in uh well i
guess it would have been an mes
technically um in environmental studies
and you know i was in an environmental
studies department so i found it very
satisfying in a way and interesting to
read a paper that was kind of a
a take not quite a takedown but like
somewhat of a challenge to the ubiquity
of this term anthropocene right that
obviously in an environmental studies
department this is like a very dominant
term that everyone uses all the time
right they talk about how we're in the
anthropocene so i think like maybe to
sort of summarize uh the argument as i
took it in in your paper and you can
kind of tell me where i go wrong but
just or if i go wrong but but just to
sort of like i guess sort of simplify
and i think it comes up um i mean i took
a bunch of quotes from your paper
and i think what was sort of
uh or i guess one thing that i want to
get clear about in the argument rather
of the paper
is there's one sentence in which you're
sort of saying that this kind of
anthropocentrism
um
is
i guess like you're critiquing so sorry
people adopt the perspective of being
anti-anthropocentrism for almost like
political reasons or ethical reasons
that like we want to not be so
self-centered right and i think one of
the things your paper to put it really
simply does is to say that like
you know being like centering the human
philosophically doesn't actually mean
that you are ethically or morally kind
of like self-centered from the human
perspective right that like
so there's a point sort of that i think
people who want to resist
anthropocentrism they want to say well
because it risks that we're going to be
self-centered right and all we care
about is ourselves as human and we don't
care about the non-human world and the
environment right that's sort of i think
what motivates the adoption of those
terms right but then i think what your
paper does is you make sort of a
philosophical argument to say well
that like doesn't really make sense
because we can't help but in a way look
at things from from a human perspective
so i guess is that
like i guess how do you see the
relationship between sort of like that
moral concern or that like like
political concern about like being like
kind of humanistically egoist
and then
like the philosophical question about
just like ontologically or like
uh at the level of subjectivity at the
level of like philosophy well there is
you know just a subject there
um that happens to be a human
perspective and i think you you do
something interesting when you're
engaging with harman's work
where you say you know who is he trying
to convince right with his
object-oriented ontology like there is
something that he is making an argument
for how could that not be the human
right because uh you know for those we
haven't actually covered uh harmon on
the podcast or really many of this i
guess they call them speculative
realists
um so anyway i don't know there's a lot
there but maybe you could respond to
some of it
yeah no that's a great summary and
you're getting at the heart of what i
find really problematic with this idea
of the critique of anthropocentrism
is i'm really wondering about the
ethical dimensions of posthumanism and
the anthropocene narrative so even
drawing on somebody like graham harmon
and i'm being somewhat reductive here
for the sake of brevity but you talk all
the time about objects withdrawing from
each other withdrawing right that
there's this autopoetic development of
each individual object that can
sometimes you know combine in their
sensuousness but at the end of the day
we are so still withdrawn
um
it kind of a spurious infinity that we
you know withdrawing withdrawing and
separating and separating and separating
and separating and i i think of this
sort of tongue-in-cheek you know that
there's an ethical withdrawal um in this
perspective that is constantly seeking
to de-center the human subject because
yes there's this concern that you know
too much human centrism
is a way of destroying nature and it
oddly pits nature and humanity against
each other in a way that i find to be
far too idealistic because i mean even
in my sense of humanism i don't think
that we can just you know try to it's
not just about dominating and destroying
nature because by doing that we're not
being humanist at all because we're
undermining the very substance that we
rely on for our our living now the other
part of this too and here i kind of like
alduster has a great essay on marx and
freud and where i'm critical of altister
in some ways i love his work
in other ways and he's talking about the
the significance of marx and freud
apart from you know a lot of the
frankfurt school attempts to combine
into like a freudo marxism what
althusser shows is that what what's
significant about both freud and marx is
that they they critique the bourgeois
subject of the self-aware fully centered
fully conscious subject in different
ways marx on the one hand critiquing the
bourgeois subject of individualistic
needs by showing that it's not the
individual who determines his or her own
existence but that we are in some ways
all already determined by the our our
position within the class struggle
that class struggle is the motor of
history not the individual subject in
the same way freud shows that every
conscious subject is always already
de-centered by the existence of the
unconscious that our motivations are not
always fully self-aware self-present to
us but that our motivations are we're
not even sometimes aware you know and
that's why we repeat you know stupid
failed attempts to get something we
think we want but we repeat painful and
harmful experiences so part of my
argument is that subjects um are always
already decentered that's one thing the
other thing against the the the marxist
humanist notions of alienation i think
that
and again it comes from this you know
sort of you know end of history sort of
totality idea that we can somehow you
know fully recombine with nature and
that alienation is contingent part of my
argument is that alienation is
constitutive of what we you know we are
as subjects that we we by being
alienated that's what forces us to think
and to negate and to enact our freedom
and that's how i think we can
grasp this uh this sense of an ethics
that is not meant to disalienate
or to de-center but actually trying to
center that every time we make an
ethical act every time we act in some
way we are centering our ability to make
a change to make a transformation
another way to think of it too then you
know that my criticism of um you know
the anti-anthropocentrism stuff is if
you look at the work of somebody like
stephen shaviro or even jane bennett
who both in different ways argue for a
kind of a pan psychism the idea that not
only are you know human subjects capable
of thinking and reasoning but we should
also assume that non-human animals and
objects are also capable of thinking and
reasoning and there's a huge
anthropomorphism they argue
avowedly for a strategic anthropo
anthropomorphism and i think to myself
well hang on if you're
anthropomorphizing the non-human and
objects you're already inherently
centering human qualities right human
aspects that you're assigning to the
other so there's not really any kind of
anti-anthropocentrism here you're still
centering and valuing making value
judgments about human qualities right
now i get the the overall project here
is to try to
think you know some kind of equity
between human and the non-human and i
think that's great but as somebody like
kate soper um has put it that only human
subjects can extend moral consideration
to non-human subjects right that
there's a a uh
the way that i put it you know you know
who are you trying to convince if not
other human subjects so ultimately you
know my humanism here is not about
trying to you know re-substantialize
humanity to
get to grasp that we are all you know
constitutively alienated which is why i
even say in some ways that the the the
ideal here for me is not you know mutual
recognition with all of other people but
we invest ourselves into a specific
other that we hold as our limit right
you know say you know your your partner
in a in a a marriage relationship or or
you know your boyfriend girlfriend or or
whatever right but if you have that kind
of you know you you choose who you want
to be and that's your your limit right
in the same way that hegel talks about
love that love is a contradictory but
necessary relationship in that in my
other i see the alienation in myself and
it holds me to account right yeah so all
of all this is various different
processes of centering the subject to
act i think that's the only way we can
think ethically yeah i can actually uh
just kind of pick up on that i think one
way
i also sort of understood your argument
as like obviously not being not trying
to mount a defense of like human
centrism in kind of the way that that
those uh people who um are
anti-anthropocentrism think but rather
to just be like this risk that you think
is entailed
by like acknowledging this the set the
centeredness of of the human aren't
actually like necessary risks or the
risks aren't there if you take it up in
the right way if you understand
at least the way that you uh explain
humanism
um but i wondered you know the the sort
of follow-up to that is you know in some
of my own work um i kind of observed a
symmetry with some of the observations
you're making about the
anti-anti-anthropocentric
crowd
and um in some of the political theory
that i engage with they kind of call it
like
post-foundationalism sort of um you know
the radical democrats and i sometimes
think
um or i've i've i accuse them sort of
being crypto-normativists in a way
because like they they kind of pretend
you know that they don't need to appeal
to anything um
to any sort of like foundation or any
sort of like ethical claim in some ways
they want to avoid making normative
claims altogether right they just want
to talk about the disruption in the
political order and like the political
moment they don't want to like have to
appeal to any sort of class like
explicit normative claims
and i mean maybe this doesn't map on
perfectly but the one i ask you victor
where are these crypto normativists
in one name one
that's true
please name one yeah
exactly i think i think i think i think
uh laclaum i think ron sierra is a
crypto normativist i think foucault is a
crypto normativist no i mean who's an
anti-normativist in the way that you're
describing because you have probably two
of them in this in this zoom call right
now
what do you mean who are the who are the
anti-normativists
yeah
well they're crypto-normativists so they
they think that there's a risk i guess i
guess the symmetry i was trying to get
to is i feel like there's a perception
of a risk that when you make normative
claims you're somehow going to fall
victim to like
some reductive thinking well what i mean
to say is to critique foundations or to
critique universalisms is not to say
that no norms exist i just want to jump
in here okay so reza negrostani has a
really really great point that i like
you know that speaks to this is that
there is no way to articulate anything
that is anti-normative right that every
critique of a norm is at the same time
the articulation of a new one the
position from which you're making
you know your critique of the normative
claim so when you say crypto normative i
think that and this is part of what what
i want to do as well is that i think
that there is in a lot of post-humanism
as i've tried to describe it an inherent
or an implicit humanist ethics that is
being disavowed right that it's not and
this i mean it it's kind of the problem
that i have even with you know uh you
know a fukodi and anti-foundationalism
or anti-normativism
you know you see this in foucault's um
uh essay what is enlightenment where
he's arguing in favor of the
enlightenment ethic for constant
critique but against the normative value
judgments of humanism that there's this
kind of inherent politics of endless
negation you know negate negate negate
negate negate which kind of puts you in
this sort of you know elitist you know
chair that you can always look down and
you know in the safe position of the
critic i can pills give me a second i
can see you want to jump in there but um
this you know constantly but if every
time if your only action is to negate
negative gate negate you're always at
the same time propping up something else
as being in power so at a certain point
you have to you know you can't just
negate you have to affirm what you stand
for what is what is it you would like to
impose to create a much more ethical or
equitable uh form of society but just is
that is that is that like the tours are
we we when we first started the podcast
sorry to interrupt you but like the very
first episode or one of the very first
episodes we did was on that litur
article has critique run its course or
something like that and that's why does
critique run out of steam yeah yeah
anyway sorry i don't i mean
the problem that i have with the you
know i mean critique
criticism i mean all these things you
know have you know there's uh
uh
you know
the the way to understand them is very
different and i kind of take the tours
you know is critique out of steam sort
of in the same vein that i take susan's
son tags against interpretation or even
to losing guitar he's
anti-interpretivism because i think that
there is still i have i have difficulty
with the ethics of a criticism that is
pure absolute negation but i still think
that interpretation and narrative
construction the way that frederick
jamison talks about when he says that
narrative is a socially symbolic act i
still think that this type of critique
is essential and important if we are
going to think about ways to enact a
kind of an ethics right so i don't think
critique has run out of steam in that
sense but i didn't want to speak now
again to this idea of
anti-foundationalism and it reminds me
of the way that somebody like
you know in yapada of attacks there's no
outside language there's no metal
language right and i think that the
lacanian and hegelian perspective
doesn't necessarily disagree with that
but defends the idea that the only way
to arrive at any conception of truth is
by beginning by positing some kind of
foundational idea
against which all of our reasoning
proceeds
so that we can pause it you know this
you know pause this idea and try to
think about it logically rationally and
come to the end point where we realize
you know where does the contradiction
enter and it's only by doing this that
we can come to truth not by getting rid
of foundations or deconstructing
foundations or getting rid of you know
positive ideas but to actually think
through reasonably the idea is that
we're positing to determine whether or
not they are true or false so i don't i
i don't believe that there is any kind
of actual anti-foundationalism i think
that every form of critique is
inherently
founding uh some kind of normative value
judgment against which it's allowing
itself to reason all various different
possibilities and the quote you know the
question is uh i i guess i'm an odd kind
of materialist because or i i don't try
to think in the you know a heideggerian
scent of what is you know what is
ontologically
true in in being but i like to begin
actually you know what is our ontology
proposing for us ethically
right what is the what are the ethics
implied and i start to think of all
ontology as in one way or another um a
kind of a legitimization or a
justification of various different forms
of ethical commitments
yeah i really like that negrostani uh
quote by the way i actually i i copied
it because i've never read it that thing
i think you mentioned it earlier about
uh yeah we cannot critique norms with
that at the same time producing them or
whatever and i thought i really i really
appreciated that in some ways you know
reading your article again uh sort of
reiterating that i'm not that ensconced
in this literature but i have you know i
really like lacan uh i've spent a lot of
time reading lacan and i even published
something like about
lacan and uh and sustainability but but
it's not like my main area and um
you know it was interesting to me to
read your paper because it was almost
like i don't know if you've ever had
this sensation where you kind of have
like a vague sense of like where you
stand on something that like you don't
know that much about and then you read
something and you're like yes this is
like putting into words
the stand that i vaguely felt like i had
yeah i i think um i i guess i i saw like
a one-two punch in this article um
one of them centers on the idea of a
performative contradiction
and the other one centers on the idea
that
what we're seeing
in post-humanism with its sort of
radical de-centering of the human is a
rather than a critique what it seems to
be offering as a reflection of the
cultural contradictions and the
contradictions of capitalism
so in a sense you know to make almost
like the delusion phrase to like make
yourself a body without organs is almost
to make yourself completely pliable to
the postmodern situation
that we're in which involves a kind of
mutation of the symbolic sphere
now what i mean by that is referencing
you get this from jameson and g-jek the
idea that there's been a
a uh a breakdown of symbolic efficiency
or a break in the chain of signification
and this is really what for you defines
post-modernity is this sort of decline
or or this
the slippage of symbolic efficiency so
i mean there's a there's a few ways to
come at this one of the ways is there's
no longer a kind of prohibition to our
enjoyment that we are now sort of
encouraged to enjoy we're prohibited
from not enjoying
in a certain way right and and
post-humanism sort of seems to come to
reflect that imperative
in its own structure
and
maybe you can maybe you can expand on
that
and
what i see you then moving towards
obviously in this article is you're
offering up a kind of aesthetic category
the again we've spoken about this
already that the sublime the
technological sublime as a way of
reading almost as a way of interpreting
aesthetically the
productions of social media of cinema
and film and those sorts of things
so maybe
i guess beginning with the performative
contradiction
i mean i think that's that just really
has to do with um
the post-humanist literature saying
we're going to de-center the human but
we're really still interested in human
survival right
one of the sort of
examples of that you know you might
remember
from early days of covid is when demand
fell
quite a bit there's all these articles
that came out about oh nature is coming
back nature is
sort of restoring itself and we go aha
there we go we just got to take humans
out of the picture and nature will do
fine kind of thing but really that's all
for us we want we are the ones who want
to survive and so
to build then to go ahead and
build this sort of
post-humanist philosophy that reflects
the contradictions of capitalism rather
than critiquing them in a certain way
we're just in a sense we're just digging
ourselves into a deeper theoretical
ditch i guess you could say rather than
actually addressing the contradictions
inherent in
say post-modern capitalism is that maybe
you can respond to something in there
yeah sure okay so there's a lot to
unpack there what you're you're kind of
pointing to let me begin with this idea
of the performative contradiction and
you can see it
in some of the language of or the
rhetoric of anthropocene the
anthropocene narrative or the discourse
where on the one hand the very idea of
an anthroposcene
suggests that
human
beings or human culture
and it's not you know the the difference
is not necessarily articulated
um and even the dating of the
anthropocene is um up for debate um
you've all know a harare for instance
and homodeus
says that we should start counting the
anthropocene some 70 000 years ago
some um writers say um 8 000 years ago
with the beginning of farming the
neolithic revolution
paul krutzen who is the the chemist who
has popularized the term dates it to the
industrial revolution some people date
it to
um european colonialism and imperialism
others dated to the post-world war ii uh
situation beginning with the the the the
dropping of the atomic bombs on uh
hiroshima and nagasaki and the you know
the post-war consumer culture the great
acceleration it's called so there's
various different ways to date um the
the anthropocene but one thing that
sticks out even the very idea of
anthropocene is that there is something
exceptional about human beings or human
culture that has caused this
conundrum that we're all in at the same
time
a lot of the anthropocene and post-human
discourse wants to say wants to resist
anthropocentrism it wants to resist this
idea of there's anything that is
exceptional out here about human beings
so on the one hand the claim is humans
are the exceptional cause but on the
other hand humans are not exceptional at
all and are in some kind of monistic
oneness relationship
with nature and i've seen arguments even
made that when humans are acting upon
the world that's just nature acting upon
itself so if nature is acting upon
itself at what point do we find this
exceptional human subject or culture or
human being that is supposedly
responsible for this condition that
we're in so that's the kind of the
performative contradiction that i'm
trying to highlight there um
and even again as i've tried to say
before with victor's question this idea
that we're trying to de-center a human
subject but it's only the centering of a
human subject that can act ethically to
respond to the conditions and that we're
in now just another part of your
question you're talking about in
post-humanism
does in some ways
articulate
the flaws or the contradictions in human
subjectivity various humanist ideologies
and so forth and i guess one of the ways
i want to i try to think about this and
this is where you can come back to hegel
and the difference between you know a
bad or a spurious infinity and hegel's
true infinity so the bad spurious
infinity this idea of you know you begin
from a point and then you move on
forever right that's just a straight
line going on forever and ever and ever
or even the way i describe graham
harmon's you know um notion of
withdrawal that it's you know infinite
withdrawal and splicing into you know
more and more multiples and multiples
and multiples forever and ever whereas
hegel says we should think the true
infinity not as this moving on in a
straight line forever but in terms of a
a cycle of a circle right so that you
can begin for instance with the moment
of initial positioning as and i put it
before you pause it the idea even if you
think about you know the positing of the
sublime in some way right the sublime
out there is nature or the sublime of
technology or as i try to develop this
idea of historical sublime as the human
as such as the enemy but it's the
initial positing that then allows us to
move from a positing reflection to an
external reflection so we see ourselves
outside of ourselves and that's where i
think post-humanism is kind of stuck in
this initial moment of negation from the
initial positing that it's stuck in this
moment of external reflection and is
kind of caught there in limbo without
really being able to move back in the
circle form to come back to the place of
the beginning to think what should we do
next which in hegel's terms is the
negation of the negation which you know
is kind of interesting because i think
that there's an important difference
between the way that hegel articulates
the negation of the negation and the way
that marx articulates the negation of
the negation not just in his early work
but in his later work in the sense that
the negation of the negation is the next
historical movement in a linear
progression of history whereas i think
in hegel and this is where it's similar
to psychoanalysis it's not about
historical movement of progression but
it's the progression of the subject to
externalize itself to look you know from
the outside looking in to then and the
moment of determinant reflection to come
back to the place of beginning and say
well no i actually have the freedom to
change the presuppositions that i
posited to rethink the problem in
another new and different uh way
so i think that um that's kind of where
i want to go with the with this idea of
a rethinking of humanism to come back at
the end of the circle to rethink the
initial presuppositions for me that you
know change the initial presupposition
that distinguishes what i'm doing from
the marxist humanists is not to think of
alienation as contingent but to think of
it as constitutive of subjectivity where
i'm differing from the anti-the
post-structuralistic humanists is not to
think about an ethics of de-centering
but to think about how we're always
already constitutively decentered and
that the point is to try to even in the
process of analysis to center the self
to be able to perform an ethical act
now the other thing i want to say though
just quickly this idea of a center
is that
i think that it's actually very and this
is where you know the problem of
post-modernism and enjoyment do we get
rid of all authorities and prohibitions
i guess a good way to distinguish
between modernism and post-modernism you
could say that if modernism was you know
this condition where we are prohibited
from enjoying you know foucault has this
whole thing about you know where there's
power there's resistance wherever you
say no there's a resistance so modernism
is you know the law of the father that
tells you no type of thing whereas in
post-modernism it's not that we're
prohibited from enjoying but we're
constantly obligated to enjoy now the
difficulty with making enjoyment an
obligation removing power authority and
centers is that you have no enjoyment
you have no ability to resist anything
there's no nothing you can transgress
the only way that you can have
experimentation and play is if you're
experimenting against some norm some
center right if you eliminate all of
this then you have nothing to grapple
with nothing to respond to so i actually
think that removing the center removing
um that you know
sort of limitation prohibition is
actually much more debilitating and
that's why i think you know today
there's so much more anxiety of you know
you're not only pro you're not
prohibited you're obligated to enjoy but
i don't know how i should enjoy what
should i do how do i you know and then
you know jijek likes to you know give
all those examples you know you have the
cosmo articles these are the steps you
need to take to get the man or the woman
of your dreams you know type of things
this is the way you should have healthy
living but none of it ever brings any
actual pleasure because our pleasure
comes from that moment of being able to
resist and you know possibly a a a a a
contentious argument here but i start to
think about you know cnn type liberals
who love having a figure like trump
right because you get the enjoyment from
saying this is the bad guy this is who i
can resist you know right wing nut bars
sorry um love having critical race
theory because they can enjoy you know
criticizing you know that side of thing
so you always have to have some kind of
an enemy that's why we love we love
critiquing jordan peterson and james
lindsay i mean it's yeah you know
don't get me started on those
i'm just saying i mean i'm just saying
it's yeah it's undeniable that there's
quite a bit of an enjoyment an eruption
of enjoyment that we get from kind of
like engaging with them and laughing at
them like i mean it's it's it's
undeniable i have to say being at the
peterson
debate was probably one of the greatest
experiences uh i've had the the the the
amount of um um i don't even like i
think like the orgy porgy of enjoyment
that you got from that audience was
spectacular oh yeah that was it was
great i want to just if you don't mind
pick up on a couple things that you said
there that that were interesting to me i
guess
well the first one when you're sort of
talking about um
you know the need to have something to
resist as like kind of essential to
enjoyment and sort of like the confusion
that people have because they don't know
how to enjoy right and i think that that
whole
theoretical framework or like that way
of framing things is pretty helpful for
like understanding things like the
culture war but you know i also thought
about john waters you know that humorist
i think he said something once about how
like you know you you see these shifting
tides
in sort of like what the dominant norms
are so like he in this example he talks
about like eating mcdonald's right and
like it became
like you know kind of an ironic thing
that people only eat when they're
hungover right they're like ashamed to
eat it and then john waters was like you
know the truly subversive thing is to
eat mcdonald's unironically you know
like for dinner now right and it's like
right exactly exactly like because
you're like i'm gonna have mcdonald's
for dinner you know it's that's what
we're having tonight like unironically
you know and it's like just shows you
the way like
we are always like shifting back and
forth trying to adopt some some
attitude towards thing that will as you
say like give us an attitude or like a
position of resistance or something to
it so let me pitch something to you what
if we un-ironically impose limitations
right right if we un-ironically instead
of negating limitations what if we
un-ironically have the freedom to say no
we are going to create laws where we
cannot just you know put chemicals into
the ground to suck up little drops of
oil right what if we put in a law and a
limitation that says no you cannot you
know have this much air travel or you
cannot you know industrially kill
animals uh you know in the way that we
do today what if we unironically impose
our own limits and in that way create a
much more universally free society
that's exactly what i'm trying to say
when i'm defending a renewal of humanism
yeah do you think um you know that
i'm not sure how close you consider
yourself to like zhizhak's philosophy
but you know even not just at the level
of putting limitations on things like
policies you know and laws but i've
heard jack say um you know what that he
loves kind of like politeness and
morality and like
and like and i wonder if do you think
that's for the same reason that it's
like there's something good about just
choosing to place limits right that
there are terms of behavior and maybe
it's okay to have norms uh
like rather than and maybe that's also
why he talks about the postmodern father
who you know talks to the child and
confuses them and says you know if you
your grandmother really loves you so you
should go see her
rather and it's better he says just to
say you're going to see your grandmother
right is that connected
i didn't think of it that way but you're
raising a very useful point and i think
that you know
there's something that we gain
even socially you know by forms of
politeness propriety uh you know it's
level you like to use this you know the
example of you know you offend somebody
and then you apologize and they say oh
you didn't have to apologize
right but the only you can only say you
didn't have to after the act has already
been done so it would seem to negate the
entire gesture but there's actually a
surplus that's accomplished in the
gesture itself you can only refuse the
apology or you know say it wasn't
necessary after it's already been given
but what you gain from that that it
looks like you didn't have to what you
gained from that is a social bond you
gain uh you know you know respect and
camaraderie and i think that these are
things that are essential to any kind of
you know
not just collective organization between
people but even a reflection of our
sense of self because i think that one
of the things not in the sort of robber
brand of spirit of trust type of way but
i think that one of the the the problems
that we face today especially in sort of
neoliberal hyper-competitive types of
society is that we can't really you know
we we we end up acting as individuals
because there's a breakdown of trust
because we are put into cons into
situations where we're constantly acting
in competition with each other but we're
never you know able to build real forms
of lasting trust and you know be
vulnerable with other people and i think
that when we're talking about imposing
certain types of limits part of that
means you know i choose this person that
i'm going to trust that is going to hold
me to account for my misdoings and by
doing that i'm actually gaining much
more freedom i'm actually gaining more
freedom being able to choose who's going
to be the limit of my activity
yeah totally i mean it even reminds me
uh
you know maybe surprisingly but and it's
in my mind because i've been teaching it
in my tutorials i work you know i'm
doing uh one of those history political
thought tutorials right now we're on
john locke and hobbs we did a hobbes
before and it kind of reminds me of like
you know their argument is often like
yes you're giving up some kind of
freedom by you know uh you know uh
giving up your freedom to the to the
comp to the um sovereign to the
leviathan and hobbs's case
but you're actually like gaining another
kind of freedom um and i don't know i
mean obviously there's a lot of public
problems with hobbs like you know i
don't i don't i don't like a lot of
stuff he says but i feel like there's
something just to that point um
that this could give you another example
i mean some people would say i've
debated with people and i don't want to
go into it too much here but the
difference between you know leviathan
and say freud's civilization is
discontents because and i prefer
civilization as discontent because you
know what freud is saying is that
you know it's
we when we enter into civilization we
have to give up some of our you know
basic inclinations but what we gain is
so much more valuable because we have a
community of people that are going to
help us and to take care of us and we
might feel the discontent you know in
the in
in in the culture from being you know
limited and prohibited and repressed in
that way but at the same time we're
actually creating a society that is
universally free where we have to create
limits but those limits actually grant
us much more freedom because i don't
have to worry anymore
if you know you victor you're going to
come and smash my house and take all of
my possessions or whatnot right there's
a social contract that you know says
that i can be protected um in my um
in my own house yeah totally uh
and i wonder like i earlier i wanted to
like read this quote from your paper
actually i mean it kind of takes us back
to the sort of like um
question of performative contradiction
but i guess i see a link i mean i think
it is linked
between sort of like this idea of trying
to well maybe you can tell me if it's
linked at least this is this is the
sense i'm getting but like you know this
this sort of like desire or this weird
tendency to like feel like
rhetorically we want to avoid limits all
the time but like
the usefulness of some limits and i
think and so here you're talking about
i guess this
i don't know do you see like this this
um
drive to avoid anthropocentrism almost
as like a kind of drive to just like
avoid limits or something or like to
escape from this or maybe i'm making a
connection that isn't there no i don't
think that's a bad way of putting it let
me actually something i wanted to say in
response to eric before i was thinking
about you know in the context of covid
and you know the you know the the kova
19 vaccine and so on i think i was
thinking about um you know jane bennett
has some part in her book vibrant matter
where she's arguing for an idea
of a of a vital materialism where we
recognize the vitality and the agency of
not only humanity but also all non-human
matter and ethically we should be driven
by a policy that says do no harm to any
form of matter but then think about what
we've been dealing with the last two
years you know do we really say you know
maybe you know again i'm being facetious
somewhat but maybe not um you know let's
not do any harm to the coronavirus let's
not kill off the virus right um i think
that
there's you know when we talk about
freedom we're not just talking about a
free choice of these are the various
options and then we choose one as if
it's a buffet but we're talking about
the choice to do what is necessary in
ultimately contingent contin decision
one way to think dialectics is even to
try to grasp how necessity arises out of
pure contingency and in some situations
to you know
and you know historically and
politically this is going to vary
there's no no one-size-fits-all solution
but given the context and this is you
know maybe even somewhat you know you
know kantian
critique of practical reason but in you
know the the categorical imperative you
know act in a way that your actions are
universally acceptable we do what's
necessary and we place limits and
conditions that are necessary to enhance
our freedom um and our survival in that
way does that kind of does that make
sense or
i think this is what distinguishes let's
say a la canyon um you know political
ethic from say a delusion with aryan
political ethic i think that you could
say from delusion guitaree that it's the
imposition of limits that actually
creates lack and contradiction whereas
for
and for hegel lacking contradiction are
inherent so you can think the difference
between the two is that for the lizard
watery and even their kind of spinozism
that what's affirmative is the layer
beneath and that what's superimposed on
top the limitations is actually creates
the the limitations of the lacks or the
gaps the contradictions so their whole
ethic is it should try to negate those
limits whereas for the khan
the the lack and the contradiction is
always inherent in zizex ontology uh
reality is incomplete that the
contradiction is a sign of reality's
incompleteness and that the lack is
always there so that the most freedom we
have is actually imposing the limits
upon which we can grasp contradiction
and then act freely
yeah right i mean uh i'm glad you
brought up to losing guitar it's kind of
an ongoing thing on this podcast where i
have no no no no no i you want a limit
i'm imposing a limit i'm not allowed
i'm not allowed okay well i just let me
make a quick comment so the reason the
reason for this limit in this case is an
ethical one and it's because
the law of the father is coming down
because i already know what you're going
to ask because it's the thing that you
ask cause you've been poisoned by by
heart and negri
but
the law of the father in this case is
gonna be that you have to read the thing
that you want to bash on before you bash
it it's an ongoing art it's an ongoing
debate i haven't read delize and guitar
yet
i i i haven't read it to losing guitar
yet but like everything that i hear
about them like makes me not want to
like them and just like what you just
said there makes me like just
basically is um
giving me more reason although it's not
fair like i i i like my own kind of
intellectual virtues prevent me just
i'll just happen and i'll say that i
advocate reading reading everything and
anything read everything and anything so
never let anything deter you you'll
learn just i'm just saying i'm happy to
hear you say what i'm happy to hear you
say what you said
because it's just like justifying more
my initial and i know that pills and
eric are both much more sympathetic to
delis so so anyway and i know they don't
have time to mount the defense right now
so okay sorry guys i just i just wanted
to get that out there um i think i think
for the um
for the final sort of section here then
um
we got to the point about talking about
um the way in which post-humanism is
taking place in this concept in this
context of the uh
breakdown of the signifying chain uh the
uh the decay of the of symbolic
efficiency
there's no longer this prohibition
to
our enjoyment it's actually a kind of
it's actually a kind of imperative to
enjoy so where do we find the
prohibitions now
and i think one of the
maybe the best way to
summarize all of this is to turn to this
idea you bring up of the hysterical
sublime
which as you say the hysteric
is one who refuses the identification
of the f i i think in in lacanian in
terms of the the identification with the
phallic signifier the one who says to
the big other
you know not that this is what i am but
like
why is why is this what you want me to
be this is sort of what the hysteric
says
um and then now jumping over to this um
concept of the hysterical sublime
which
to me has very practical applications
because you can use it as a way of
reading social media as a way of reading
film maybe you could just walk us
through
how we can think about
the hysterical sublime
in
in our everyday engagement with media
perhaps maybe that's a good way to take
it because um i think in in this essay
we're discussing um
uh renewing humanism against the
anthropocene the last couple sections
are taken with this idea of um
of the hysteric and the sublime uh we
already mentioned the sublime comes from
kant and burke and um
and uh jameson
sort of
brings up this idea of the hysteric
sublime we already went over that but
how what's a practical sort of use i
guess you could say of this of this
theoretical
aesthetic
category
so there's a there's a number of things
that you said there that i i think are
worth unpacking so i'm going to go with
the last thing you said and i'll see if
i get to the the first part about the
breakdown of the signifying chain or the
the the the demiser symbolic deficiency
so uh i i i wrote written a paper and
it'll be part of the the book um
um eventually
but again
one way so you can't understand the
hysterical sublime the sublime part i
want to say first um you can't
understand it without first thinking
about what it's what what jamison was
trying to do and i've i already said
this in burke and konto we're talking
about the positing of an irrational
external nature against uh humanity for
burke the idea is that you can enjoy the
irrationality of nature from a safe
space for kant the idea of the sublime
is that we pause it in some way our
superiority over nature to put ourselves
into the picture and it's through this
aesthetic in the sense of experiencing
the world through our senses right not
necessarily representation right but
that the representation only comes after
we posit our position our human position
relative to nature that we can then
think and for me what the sublime
does
is it's again it's a way of positing the
presuppositions
that against which then we can represent
in our thinking in our discourse in
language as a way of then reasoning the
situation so that the elimination of the
sublime
is almost a way of saying that we want
to get rid of the representation and
that there's a level of unthinking that
is going to
take place it's a way of removing
thinking now this is important to me
because if you see in post-humanist
thinkers like graham harmon who argues
in his own aesthetic theory he wants to
get rid of this distinction between the
beautiful and the sublime that we see in
kant uh for instance that he says that
we should you know view you know a
sunset and we shouldn't view a sunset
and a tsunami
any different then we'd experience
you know a beautiful painting of flowers
that everything again in object
unoriented ontology the idea is that all
things are objects real objects and
they're all you know equivalent you know
it's not necessarily the same the same
type of stuff so he wants to get rid of
this distinction between the beautiful
um
and the sublime my argument is that even
still in post-humanism there is some
positing of a sublime which for me is
this idea of the human it's the against
the human that the representation and
the reasoning is taking place but in the
this aesthetic sense one of the things
i'm also doing susan buck morse has this
really really great
article that i hope everybody still
reads in grad school on vulture
benjamin's artwork essay on uh what's
called anesthetics and she's responding
to the final lines of
vulture benjamin's the work of art in
the age of mechanical reproduction
where he says something along the lines
of
fascism
aestheticizes politics and the goal of
communism is to politicize aesthetics
and part of what i think is taking place
with post-humanism in its various
different forms through the
the avowed
kind of elimination of the sublime but
then the disavowed positive of the human
subject as their own sublime is to me a
kind of an aestheticization of politics
in the way that we're meant to
reintegrate our bodies into the
uh
the the the sensuousness of the natural
world to get rid of representation to in
some ways and i get i'm being reductive
here um so don't hold me to this but to
get rid of forms of critical rational
dialectical thinking dialectical
thinking particular and to just become
one with nature and i think this is a
very dangerous thing especially in the
way that's even
substantializing some nature right some
other
even you know the way that we
substantialize you know god in a certain
way right is the substantialization of
the other that i think is very dangerous
right and for me what the aesthetic and
representational aesthetics should be
about is a way to posit um
the positive the presuppositions that
allow us to think critically rationally
dialectically that's only from this that
we're able to think ethically so for me
aesthetics and ethics are very much in
combination with each other because it's
only through the representational
aesthetics that were able to think into
reason and to come to terms with the
ethical situation that we're presented
with so the practical dimension of
hysterical sublime here is on the one
hand to think about what is being
posited
in the post-humanist argument um as
sublime i'm arguing that the human
subject is positive as the sublime other
a post-humanist um um theory but also in
the the psychoanalytic sense the
hysteric is important here right because
as you said eric um this idea of the
hysterics is the one who says you know
to the other you know why am i what you
are saying that i am why am i you know
this person man woman whatever why am i
this why am i this thing and a way to
think about hysteria is as a form of
failed interpolation right the subject
emerges the subject as such for lacong
is the hysterical subject right in this
moment of interpolation failing the
ideology failing saying why am i what
you are saying that i am and it's in
fact in the hysterics questioning that
the analytical discourse is produced
that psychoanalysis is really the
product of trying to understand the
hysterical question the hysteric is kind
of like the proletariat of freud's
psychoanalysis because it's the
the hysteric who is questioning the
authority of the other and the analyst
who has to come in and interpret and
help the hysteric the subject themselves
to create a narrative construction
that then allows them to engage again
with the world in lacan's ethics the
ethics of you know the only thing that
one can be guilty of is giving grounds
relative to one's desire and if desire
is this constant process of
negation negation negation i get this
object that's not it i get this object
that's not it i get this object that's
negation negation negation at a certain
point you realize that you cannot negate
any further
and you have to on your own create the
conditions that allow you to enjoy
coming to terms with the fact that your
enjoyment is only in the fantasy and now
it lies beyond the fantasy right that
you enjoy by imposing your own limit you
enjoy the fantasy but you still have the
freedom to create the conditions of your
own enjoyment
and in a sense in that way we sort of
continue to
rehearse
this um fantasy which brings us back to
the
constitutive lack
that is what gives birth to the subject
in the first place
and the goal here then is to sort of
traverse the fantasy
um and i guess in lacanian terms be
become
take the position of the analyst in a in
a way
uh you traverse the fantasy in that
sense and in doing that right what we're
doing one of the things i like the
examples i like to use is that stupid
old you know hippie thing if i'm going
to go and find myself right i i get this
idea and no my i don't like to say i'm
going to be something else i want to
find something else but the whole
process is to come back to your position
from the beginning and finding yourself
of what you always already were right
that you made the choice of the limit
that you imposed upon yourself and you
in the end find yourself by coming back
to realizing i'm the one who chose the
limit that uh that is what i am and the
analyst position is this you know when
you traverse the fantasy you don't get
rid of the fantasy you don't get the
thing that was lost in the fantasy but
you realize that you have the ability to
impose the limit and to still enjoy
in the fantasy right that you know
you're not trying to get what's beyond
and this is that again you don't you
know it's not this moment of i'm at the
end of analysis and i can just go on and
you know be a uh you know a self you
know independent person the point of the
analytical relationship is that you
always have to maintain that relation
with the little other with the small
other of some other person that you are
engaged with that you would trust this
is why in some ways you could talk about
the analytical relationship as uh not to
be too hippy-dippy about it but as a
relationship of love right not romantic
or sexual or whatever kind of love but
love as a you know a choice of this
person that is going to hold me to
account you know and it persists
right and when we use the technological
sublime or right sorry the hysterical
sublime
is
am i okay to put it this way that we use
say film
or
i mean your book algorithmic desire we
can also use sort of social media
as as you say as a sort of metaphor for
the form of ideology
that structure is the big other today um
do these things help us traverse the
fantasy then when we apply this category
of the technological or sorry i keep
saying that hysterical sublime i don't
think that there's anything that can
help us to traverse the fantasy other
than the analytical interpretive work
that i don't think that you watch a film
and it's going to be this aha moment
okay that's what i have to do i think
that it's actually if you want to do it
this way it's in the practice in my my
first book which was on check in film i
conclude by actually arguing that no
film is ever going to you know give us
the answer of what we have to do it's
rather in our own action of interpreting
of interpretation when we're engaged at
the level of interpretation that's when
we start to develop this kind of you
know self-consciousness self-awareness
in the process of doing the interpretive
work that then leads us towards uh um
and ethics now in terms of its
representation in film and popular
culture and even in social media
hysterical sublime for me again the way
that jameson talks about it is the
depiction of technology that figures
that represents the sublime of the other
of post-modern capitalism technology
that is this representation of the the
sublime the post-modern uh the other of
the post-modern uh capitalism and what
makes it so you know the panic mode of
that is when we start to realize that
the development of technology is an
outgrowth not necessarily of human
society but of a particular you know
capitalist society for jamison
hysterical sublime the the technological
aspect of it is a representation of the
networks of global capitalism so the
technology comes to figure or represent
or acts as a metaphor of the problems
and contradictions the fissures
of of the networks
of global capitalism and this is what
i'm hoping that it can accomplish you
know at the interpretive analytical
level
is to think about how our historical
condition is not one of a substantial
you know human
problematic but it's a it's a problem of
the way in which our world now is
organized according to the logics of the
capitalist vote of production and in
other ways i try to say that even if
it's not all of humanity that has caused
this problem all of humanity is still
impacted by it all of humanity is still
implicated in it and in just in the way
that you know marx talks about the
proletariat as the symptom of the
capitalist mode of production of the
capitalist economy i think that today we
can in a similar way say that humanity
is the symptom of the capitalist ecology
that all of humanity is the dejected
symptom of being run not by humanity but
by a system by an object by a series of
a network of objects so that the way to
envision class struggle today is the
class struggle between capitalism and
those who defend it and the rest of us
humanity all right i was gonna wrap it
up but now i have a follow-up question
based on
you know i'm implicated in this too
because it's i'm not against i i know as
a person with type 1 diabetes i am
conditioned by the nature of my own
biology i rely on technology to
keep me alive insulin i actually live
with like a
constant glucose monitor and i use my
phone technology to
check myself but it's neither the nature
or technology that is driving us i want
to say but it's that the human decision
you know of how to plan and to act that
this is something that is very much part
of the way to rethink humanism the
planning aspect of it so i'm only saying
that because i have to go have a snack
soon because of my blood sugar oh okay
so you do you want to go now or one more
question okay okay great thanks so we'll
wrap we'll rep shortly
so
within this capitalist mode of
production that you kind of finished off
with there and and couple that with the
hysterical situation
how do you
non-arbitrarily
reset that limit that you're talking
about because the non
whatever that non-arbitrariness is and i
think it's going to be something related
to the humanism that you're talking
about here but the non-arbitrariness of
that limit is going to be somewhere
where the beginning of this ethics is
found
so can you just explain how do you mean
the the arbitrariness
as opposed to the non-arbitrariness
well juice
loves the limit it requires it even so
when you describe the situation of
consumption in which there is no limit
where the compulsion is to unlimit or
delimit or freely consume the command is
to enjoy arbitrarily
so if that's the state for the consumer
and not just eating mcdonald's but you
know perpetually
reacting to tweets or content if that's
the state we have
then every limit you set up on enjoyment
is
at least in my view
merely an aesthetic choice it's
arbitrary so going vegan is a personal
brand decision as opposed to an ethical
one if if consumption is the only law
so are the limits you are proposing to
reproduce here are they purely arbitrary
or is there some hierarchy of
meaningfulness or ethicalness in the
limits that you decide to set okay
that's a good question i get it now so
one way okay i'm gonna i'm sorry i know
i'm long-winded but i think that a good
point of contrast would be the startra
of being in nothingness because i think
that what i'm absolutely not talking
about and what i'm against very much is
a kind of a purely liberal voluntarist
conception of choice and imposing limits
and being in nothingness sartre very
famously criticizes the freudian notion
of the unconscious that there's no such
thing as the unconscious there is only
the conscious self-aware uh sense of
the self and that we can voluntarily in
some ways i'm being reductive again
sorry um voluntarily make free choices
free decisions um in a very much you
know independent uh way and i don't
think that's the case and i think that
that's where liberalism starts to
become a problem because it's not for me
a matter of the arbitrary choice of the
individual acting on their own but of
the socially determined individual who
is acting not just on their own but
in relation to the society the culture
the community the family that we're
always already uh embedded within and
even as i described that the the
formation of subjectivity
the formation of the unconscious comes
in that well that foundational mind of
decision of i i know i am this i'm going
to negate all of those various other
things that my self-aware sense i can't
i know that i'm trying to pursue all of
these objects of desire but what remains
unconscious is that initial moment of
choice where i say to myself i am this
it seems like that's the one where we
would be conscious but actually that's
the part that is unconscious when lecon
talks about the subject of the signifier
the signifier is the unconscious aspect
of the self and we seem to consciously
want to pursue all these various other
objects of desire that lie out there
right
so that the point of coming to realize
the way in which i set my limit doesn't
come from a you know this you know
arbitrarily arbitrarily you know active
decision i choose i'm going to be this i
choose i'm going to be that it's only by
entering into the analytical
relationship with the small other
whether that's analysis you know you
know
you know my partner my friends my family
my community it's only by entering into
the relationship and the dialogue with
the with with you know in this way that
we can then come to say we're going to
choose the limit now the limit here is
not just you know individual and
subjective because it also has to be
universal and this is a very important
to galilean point right that freedom is
not just the freedom of the individual
to act independently you know the way
that you know the libertarian notion of
freedom without limits or the you know
the you know the trucker convoy notion
of freedom of i don't want to live by
the law of getting vaccinated and
wearing masks
because if you think about freedom only
in that independent individualistic
arbitrary way
then sooner or later your freedom comes
into competition with the freedom of
everybody else and we're back into that
hobby and lucky and state of nature type
of relationship but freedom is freedom
only exists if it is a universal
limitation a universal law where we say
you know i'm going to obey the law not
because you know the powers out there
tell me that i have to obey it but i
know that by obeying the law i'm going
to gain my freedom in the gaining of the
freedom of the other a very stupid
example that you know
i can't remember where i heard it but
you know when you go to a stoplight or
terry eagleton has this idea you know
that you know you can't just arbitrarily
decide to you know stand in front of a
speeding um um
ambulance right when we go to a stop
sign
when we're driving we just we know
nobody's there you know forcing us to do
it but we know that we shouldn't run the
stop sign because we'll you know
endanger ourselves and everybody else
right so that the limit we're talking
about is not arbitrary we understand
that it is a guarantee of our universal
universal mutual freedom
well i wish we could extend that last
point indefinitely but uh i think it's
about time
maybe i'll write a paper contending it
who am i kidding no i'm not going to do
that
maybe a podcast this is a it's a lot to
absorb um anyway check
out the article in the link below if
your curiosity has been peaked
or if you want to go over it again at
your own pace
so matt um let's say someone has heard
something interesting that you've said
here and they want to make more sense of
it or go over it at their own pace where
should they go and what should they do
so as to uh be able to chew and digest
what would you recommend
so yeah you can read my
my latest book is
as you mentioned algorithmic desire
toward new structuralist theory of
social media the the the first for me i
mean my i've written about the
hysterical sublime i have a chapter in a
book called black me uh black mirror and
critical media theory um where i talk
about the hysterical sublime um in
relation to the series black mirror oh
that sounds great i have another chapter
in a book on la ca and the environment
where i also talked about the hysterical
sublime
um the paper that you mentioned i have
another piece hopefully coming out soon
um on the aesthetic dimension of the
hysterical sublime but the book is still
in process um for uh you can check out
my website it's matthewplusfetter.com
and i guess follow me on twitter
yeah you're you're pretty active on
there so
i try not to be which is the bad part
but you are
i'm not very good at self-limiting i
guess you need to set your limits yeah i
i checked it about 10 30 this morning
and you'd already done about eight
tweets today
wow the call out eric the column
well why don't we just say enjoy your
limit um check out his stuff and thank
you matt so much for coming on uh it's
been great it's been
a lot you're probably gonna have to
listen to this episode more than once to
be able to digest all that but thank you
very much for coming
yeah it's been fun thank you yeah thanks
for coming on it was great all right
this has been uh pillpot 70 something i
think i said 74. and uh thank you very
much for listening check us out
fridays
every friday actually barely accept if
you're not a patron
well that's true but that's that's on
you
that limit is wholly arbitrary so join
us there if you want some more anyway
bye take care guys
[Music]
you